-Thank you very much,
and welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
after a crazy four days,
March Madness is down
to the Sweet 16.
That's right.
We are down to 16 teams.
Three number-one seeds
and nine million commercials
for AT&T.
Yeah.
Of course, the Cinderella story
that everyone's talking about
is the 15th-seed
Saint Peter's Peacocks
who have made it
to the Sweet 16.
It's exciting for long-time fans
who have been following the team
since Thursday.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh...
Saint Peter's is the first team
from New Jersey
to make the Sweet 16
in over 20 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's right.
And if they go all the way,
they'll be the only team
to wear their championship rings
on their pinkies.
[ Laughter ]
N-C-A-Ohh!
Hey! Ohh! This guy!
[ Laughter ]
How can you not love their name?
They're the Peacocks.
This is the best thing
that happened to NBC
since the new "Law & Order."
[ Laughter ]
I love it.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today
confirmation hearings began
for Supreme Court nominee
Ketanji Brown Jackson.
The hearing process
will last four days.
It's basically C-SPAN's version
of Coachella.
[ Laughter ]
And I saw that the top
Republican leading the hearings,
Chuck Grassley, is 88 years old.
Wow.
When it was his turn to speak,
he was like,
"Tell us who you are
and then tell me who I am."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Jackson will face days
of tough questions.
Brett Kavanaugh was like...
[Slurring] "It'll be fine.
I did it for four days.
After the s-second day...
After the --
After the second day,
it's kind of a blur. It's fine.
It's like --
You're my best friend.
Hold my hair."
[ Imitates vomiting ]
But this is cool.
I saw that
Judge Jackson's parents
were at
the confirmation hearing.
Even crazier,
so were Chuck Grassley's.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?!
-Hey, you guys
remember last year
when that huge ship
blocked up the Suez Canal?
Well, the same company that owns
that ship is back in the news,
and it's for exactly
the reason that you think.
Listen to this.
-A massive cargo ship
is stuck in the mud
off the coast of Maryland.
The vessel,
called the "Ever Forward,"
grounded in the Chesapeake Bay.
-Yeah, the "Ever Forward"
got stuck.
[ Laughter ]
Which is why they're
renaming it the "Irony."
[ Laughter ]
Every few months, the owner gets
a call from the captain like,
"Okay. Don't be mad..."
[ Laughter ]
Alright, listen to this.
I heard that Match just launched
a new dating app
for single parents called Stir.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Yep.
Their slogan is, "I'll join
your hell if you join mine."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And this is fun.
Today after a two-year hiatus,
Dairy Queen's
Free Cone Day returned!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And after
their two-year hiatus,
the McDonald's ice-cream machine
is still on hiatus.
I'm sorry.
Finally, guys, in Miami, a thief
broke into a sneaker store
and took 20 shoes.
But when he got out, he realized
he only stole the left sneakers.
[ Laughter ]
Officers were like --
[Imitates radio static]
"The suspect is 5'10",
200 pounds,
and running in circles."
No matter what happens,
I hope he realizes that 20 lefts
do not make a right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today in Washington,
it was Day 2
of confirmation hearings
for Supreme Court nominee
Ketanji Brown Jackson.
-Whoo!
-Yep, these hearings are never
really fun, but then again,
there's always a paper crinkle
to really liven things up.
Watch this.
Uh, unfortunately,
[ Page turns ]
there's a 77% record --
I'm sorry.
Let me make sure
[ Laughter ]
that this is accurate.
[ Pages turning ]
[ Laughter continues ]
[ Rubbing microphone ]
United States v Platz.
Trump-appointed
Judge Sarah Pitlyk --
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness. Yeah, yeah.
Even old people unwrapping hard
candy at the movies were like,
"Let's go, buddy, come on!"
[ Laughter ]
Chomping on gum.
I love it.
Yeah, Judge Jackson spent
all day answering questions.
Meanwhile, can we see
the Republican senators
who are asking them?
Gosh, it looks like
the Employee of the Month wall
at Cracker Barrel.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right,
today Judge Jackson spent hours
answering questions.
Most Senators didn't get
to be there,
but here at "The Tonight Show,"
we got ahold
of the questions
they would've asked.
-Really?
-Yeah, check these out.
First, we have...
They would've asked...
[ Laughter ]
That's a question they had.
-Question.
-Up next we have...
He would've asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, we have...
He would've asked..
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a hard no on that one.
What?
Some more news --
President Biden just warned
that Russia could be
exploring options
for cyberattacks
against the U.S.
Isn't that always true?
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of like saying
Michael Bublé is exploring
another Christmas album.
It's like, yeah,
pretty sure it's going
to happen.
[ Laughter ]
Biden said that they could hit
power grids and water supplies.
And people were like, "Cool,
just let us know
when TikTok's in danger, okay?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
to protect yourself online,
experts are saying
that you should make
your passwords longer
than eight characters.
[ Audience murmuring ]
Americans were like, "So,
12345678!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
Zoom has introduced
a new avatar feature
that lets users
show up to meetings
as an animal,
[ Laughter ]
like a dog, a rabbit, or a fox.
Yeah. There's nothing
like getting laid off
by a fox in the Bahamas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, a 101-year-old man
who dropped out of high school
in the 1930s
just got his diploma,
more than 80 years later.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Asked what he's going to do now,
the guy said,
"Spring break!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today was
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson's
final day facing questions
from senators
during her confirmation
hearings.
That's right, after nearly
30 hours of questions.
Whew, yeah.
Her husband was so scared to ask
what she wanted for dinner,
he just ordered
takeout from everywhere.
He's just like,
"Yeah, never mind, never mind.
Do you wanna watch Netflix --
no Netflix, okay.
We'll just put a --
let's buy another TV.
We'll put on
two things at once."
[ Laughter ]
But this is great --
according to a new poll,
Judge Jackson already has
a record approval rating
among Americans
for a Supreme Court nominee.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right now, Biden's like,
"Hey, I nominated you.
It's only fair we split
that approval rating.
Come on."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the only way
it could have been higher
is if she ended today
with a water bottle flip.
It's like, "Oh, yeah!"
In other news, despite the
current state of affairs,
Vladimir Putin is still planning
to attend the G20 summit
with other world leaders
in Bali this fall.
[ Audience oohs ]
Which explains
this year's theme...
"awkward."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, what is he doing?
It's like getting
kicked out of high school
and then showing up
for the reunion.
Like, "What's up, guys?"
"No, you were -- No."
Yeah, it'll backfire on Putin
when he realizes
it's not a G20 summit,
it's an intervention.
He's like, "Wait a minute, I --
I remember you."
Some business news,
apparently Apple has experienced
two major outages
in the past two days.
Luckily, the problem was fixed
when the guy at the Genius Bar
told Tim Cook to just drop the
entire company in a bag of rice.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, in the most recent outage,
Apple Music and Apple Books
went down,
which means no one noticed.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Apple Books?
-Apple Books.
-"Hey,
look it up on Apple Books."
Hey, I saw that Taco Bell is
celebrating its 60th anniversary
with an all-new vegetarian meal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And actually, it's
the first time anyone's ever
said "Happy anniversary"
inside a Taco Bell.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Some TV news.
CBS is releasing a new
dating competition show
called "The Real Love Boat,"
in which a big group of singles
spend nearly a
month together on a cruise.
-Ooh.
-Yep, it's the only dating show
where the winner is
whoever gets kicked off first.
[ Laughter ]
It's just like "The Bachelor,"
but instead of a rose,
you get a bottle of imodium.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I saw that today
is National Puppy Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep.
And not surprisingly,
National Puppy Day
falls on Hump Day.
[ Applause ]
Well, guys, earlier today
President Biden was in Brussels
to meet with NATO leaders for
an emergency summit on Russia.
When they voted on a resolution
to condemn Putin,
30 leaders voted "yea," and one
office plant voted "nyet."
[ Laughter ]
Anyone see that plant walk?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it was an emergency
summit, but don't worry.
NATO leaders still had time
for a family photo.
Here it is.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like the sales team at
a Honda dealership, doesn't it?
[ Laughter ]
I'm expecting them to all
say together,
"We're ready to serve you."
[ Laughter ]
Can we see it again?
Yeah.
It's a very diverse group.
There are suits of every color.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's either a NATO
summit or a conference for
"men who don't know what to do
with their arms" photo.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see the photo
just one more time?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
There we go.
[ Laughter ]
Kind of doing his own thing.
-Yeah.
-Well, changing gears,
this morning the "Today" show
investigated the dangers
of the metaverse.
And they even sent
one of their reporters in
to see what kind of activity
goes on in there.
Let's see how that went.
-We wanted to see the
concerns for ourselves,
so I put on a headset and
entered the metaverse.
That blue robot is me.
There we entered
a virtual strip club,
created and uploaded
by another user.
-I am a reporter, yes, trying to
understand the metaverse.
-[ High-pitched voice ] Oh, you
should not have come in here.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
-Amazing!
Billions spent on technology
so a cartoon weasel
can kick you out of
a fake strip club.
[ Laughter ]
[ High-pitched voice ] You
should not have come in here.
Oh, no.
Put your hands together
for Cinnamon, everybody.
[ Normal voice ] Some business
news -- due to a shortage of
ingredients, General Mills
is struggling to supply
grocery stores with
Totino's Pizza Rolls
and Pillsbury Cookie Dough.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh.
-It's serious.
As soon as he heard, Biden
called NATO back for
another emergency summit.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, when I heard there was
a T.P. shortage,
I wasn't thinking
Totino's Pizza.
[ Laughter ]
Right now General Mills is like,
"Hey, but we still have plenty
of Fiber One bars.
Hello? Anyone?
Anyone want to gnaw on
a Fiber One bar?"
[ Laughter ]
One vote said, "Nyet."
One office plant said, "Nyet."
-It was a spy. It was a Russian
spy, is what you're saying.
-What's that?
-It was a Russian spy
in that plant.
-Oh, is that correct?
-Yeah, that's what it was.
That's why it said, "Nyet."
-Oh, so you're saying it's
"30 world leaders said yes."
And then one office plant
said --
-"Nyet," which is "no"
in Russian.
-Yeah, and it was --
But a plant --
-So you're implying that it was
a spy in that plant.
That's what makes it
so humorous.
That's what I love about it.
[ Laughter ]
Topical.
-Yep, it is.
Hey, this is big though, guys.
Yesterday CEOs of every major
U.S. airline called on
President Biden to drop
the federal mask mandate.
-Ooh.
-Yep.
[ Applause ]
-Each airline actually released
its own statement about it.
Take a look.
American Airlines said...
United said...
Spirit Airlines said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And Delta said...
Then Spirit said...
[ Laughter ]
JetBlue said...
And finally, Spirit said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pretty out of the loop,
I don't know.
Hey, get this, I saw that Uber
has reached a deal
to list all New York City taxis
on its app.
And this makes sense --
they hashed out the deal
by screaming at each other
through open car windows.
"You want to sign the deal?
You sign it!"
You can't park there!
Sign the deal! You" --
[ Laughter ]
Hey, here's some good news.
I read that as kids
return to the classroom,
their test scores are going up.
It's a really nice way of saying
we all failed at homeschooling.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, first graders are already
coming home like,
[English accent] "Mother,
father, your homeschooling
efforts were rather deficient."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
I heard a new report about
where people like to eat food
in their house.
And the results might surprise
you. Check it out.
-According to a new survey
in the U.K.,
more than
one in five people say
they snack in the bathroom.
18% confessed they enjoy
their treats on the toilet.
-No!
-What?!
-You know what?
Just take me back
to the metaverse.
I think I like that.
[ High-pitched voice ]
"Welcome back, Mr. Fallon.
Here's 70 Jimmy bucks for you
to make it rain."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Finally,
researchers say that they're
getting closer to producing
the first ever
birth control pill for men.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-That's better than the original
form of male birth control --
dress socks with sandals.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this Sunday is
the 94th Academy Awards.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, the Oscars are 94,
and typical Hollywood, they're
all dating statues in their 20s.
[ Laughter ]
I can't wait.
The biggest stars
walking the red carpet,
being asked "Who are you
wearing? Who swabbed you?"
You know.
[ Laughter ]
Quick heads-up, if you hear
a piercing shriek
halfway through the show,
that's just me
when Questlove wins the Oscar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, Quest, you're
going to enjoy this, all right?
So, the Oscar gift bag this year
has a value of $140,000.
[ Audience oohs ]
$140,000.
Can we see what's in the bag?
Oh, it's gas. Oh, fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
It's a gallon of gas.
-Wow.
-A gallon -- a whole gallon.
The big nominees this year
are "The Power of the Dog,"
"CODA," "Belfast," and a bunch
of others you started streaming
and forgot to finish.
[ Laughter ]
But this is new.
I saw that this year,
there's a Fan Favorite Award
that will be decided
by a vote on Twitter.
That's why the Oscar will go
to a TikTok
of a guy falling
off a golf cart.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this year, the Oscars
are paying tribute
to "The Godfather"
for its 50th anniversary.
They'll be like -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, they're like,
"We're here to honor
all the great
'Godfather' movies --
'The Godfather,'
'Godfather: Part II.'
You know, those two movies."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the Oscars will also pay tribute
to the James Bond franchise.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It makes sense because there are
just so many classic Bond films.
I mean, here,
check out this promo
that The Academy just released.
-This year, The Academy
is excited to take a look back
at every James Bond film,
including...
[ Laughter ]
-A lot of great classics.
-Wow. Classic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Wow.
-Speaking of movies,
everyone is talking about this.
The director of "The Batman"
just released a deleted scene
showing Robert Pattinson
facing off against The Joker.
-Ooh.
-It's pretty shocking.
I had no idea that you could
release a three-hour movie
and still have deleted scenes.
[ Laughter ]
Impossible.
But the scene
is really something.
I mean, we haven't seen
a Batman face off
against The Joker in months.
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news.
Today, the second season
of "Bridgerton"
started streaming on Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah.
Mother's Day came early
this year.
Yeah, that's right.
-Oh, oi.
-At least I -- Apparently,
a lot of the fans were upset
'cause this season
has way fewer sex scenes.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
"Bridgerton"
without the sex scenes,
which explains this new
Netflix message I saw.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Isn't that weird?
Got even weirder when Netflix
added more sex scenes
to "Is It Cake?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is nice.
Today, President Biden was
in Poland visiting our troops
and even stayed for some pizza.
But I think the jalapeño slice
caught him by surprise.
Watch -- Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-You -- [ Laughs ]
You know it must have been bad
when during a pandemic,
Biden is like,
"Let me drink from your cup.
Let me --
I need something to --
Hand it over.
Just -- Just spit it
in my mouth.
Just go -- I really --
I don't --
Hot, hot, hot."
Yeah, the spice
really got to him.
And this is real.
He was still feeling it
a little later.
This is a real video.
Check it out.
[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I love that dude.
I love how he says "pizza pie."
I don't even think
Mario and Luigi say that.
[ Laughter ]
It was like,
"You know what gives me
worse heartburn that pizza pie?
Pas-- Pasketti."
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
IHOP and Pepsi have teamed up to
create the new maple syrup cola.
Here it is.
Yeah.
[ Audience ohs ]
Yeah, I'm trying to be healthy,
so I'm going to wait
'til they come out
with a diet maple syrup Pepsi.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it turns out
the executives at IHOP
are just as drunk
as the customers.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a new study
found that drinking two
to three cups of coffee a day
could add years to your life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
On the flip side, if you want
to take years off of your life,
try the new maple syrup Pepsi
from IHOP.
[ Cheers and applause ]